mes chers collègues dans la discussion
de ce projet de loi et dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Christiane tobira garde des saau
ministre de la
[Applaudissements]
Justice monsieur
président monsieur le
Président Monsieur leés Madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la présidente
de la commission des affaires sociales
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les
sénateurs avec ma collègue Dominique
Bertinotti ministre de la Famille nous
avons l'honneur de présenter au Sénat le
projet de loi qui a été adopté largement
par 329 députés pour contre 229 contre à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui vise à
ouvrir le mariage et l'adoption au
couple de même sexe ce sont à titre
principal des dispositions du Code civil
relative au mariage et à l'adoption qui
ont été modifié ainsi que les
dispositions sur le nom de famille qui
ont dû être
adapté l'article premier qui est le plus
important ouvre donc le mariage au
couple de même sexe il introduit un
article numéro 143 dans le Code civil
qui indique que le mariage peut être
contracté par deux personnes de de sexes
diff différents ou de personnes de même
sexe c'est donc un texte qui affiche
très clairement l'ambition d'atteindre à
l'égalité dans le
choix sur les formes de vie commune et
de composition de la famille c'est un
texte donc qui ouvre aux personnes du
même sexe aux coupes du même sexe le
choix et la liberté d'accès à cette
troisème forme pour organiser la vie
commune puisque ces couples ont déjà
déjà accès au concubinage qui est
l'union de fête au pacte civil de
solidarité et il n'avait pas jusqu'à ce
jour accès au mariage qui est à la fois
un contrat une institution et qui
produit des effets d'ordre public cette
disposition évidemment n'altère en rien
les droits des couples homo
hétérosexuels et des familles
hétéroparentales il n' il n'altère rien
au contraire au contraire puisque le
débat a déjà produit la possibilité
l'intention d'une évolution du droit de
la famille et notamment du statut du
parent social et qu'il y a déjà dans ce
texte des dispositions qui sont
profitables au coupes homosexuel et aux
familles aux couples hétérosexuels et
aux familles
hétéroparentales ce texte ne fragilise
pas l'institution de la famille au
contraire il la
renforce il ne met pas en péril les
enfants au contraire il les sécurise et
euh il y a des dizaines de milliers et
certains affirment même des centaines de
milliers d'enfants qui sont
concernés des centaines de milliers
d'enfants qui peuvent être
concernés certains considèrent que ce
texte correspond à une application de la
France de ses engagements internationaux
dans sa lutte contre les discriminations
et son combat pour l'égalité politique
de fait nous ne sommes pas seuls après
avoir été pionnière en
1999 avec l'adoption du pacte civil de
solidarité la France a en effet un peu
marquer le pas tandis que d'autres pays
européens les Pays-Bas la Belgique la
Norvège la Suède l'Espagne le Portugal
et bientôt définitivement la
Grande-Bretagne légalisait le mariage
entre personnes de même
sexe pendant la même décennie d'ailleurs
le Canada et compris la Belle Province
du Québec 10 états des États-Unis la
ville de Mexico Avec effet sur
l'ensemble du territoire mexicain ainsi
que la République d'Afrique du Sud
procédait de même et légalisait donc le
mariage entre personnes de même
sexe ce n'est pourtant
pas pour entrer dans un club
hypothétique de pays audacieux dont les
législations ont d'ailleurs des effets
divers que nous vous présentons ce
projet de loi c'est justement au regard
de l'histoire de la République française
et de ses valeurs la liberté et
l'égalité c'est au regard de son
évolution propre de l'empreinte laissée
sur ces
institutions par les débats les combats
les progrès juridiques et sociétaux que
nous vous soumettons ce projet de loi
mtant exprimé à ce propos à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est à grand trait que je
vais tracer les grandes étapes qui ont
consolidé l'institution du mariage c'est
en effet en
1791 après la réclamation d'un comédien
dont la profession était exclue du
mariage religieux le seul en vigueur
alors que le constituant de
1791 a instauré le mariage
civil 4 ans avant en
1787 il avait reconnu le pluralisme
religieux et autorisé le mariage de
Juifs et de protestants dont les enfants
étaient considérés comme bâtards en tout
cas pour ceux qui étaient restés en
France puisque selon les sources il
semble que plus de 300000 d'entre eux
avaient quitté le
pays en instaurant le mariage civil en
confiant à l'officier d'état civil
l'enregistrement des actes en imposant
le consentement article 146 du Code
civil inchangé depuis 1804 il n'y a
point de mariage il n'y a point de
consentement en autorisant le divorce
qui est autorisé en
1792 qui est supprimé ensuite en 1816
réétabli en 1884 par la loi nacké dans
la grande foulée de ces lois de liberté
liberté de la presse en 1881 liberté
syndicale liberté
d'association qui vont culminer avec
cette grande loi de liberté laïque pour
l'État vis-à-vis des églises en levant
toute restriction à l'accès au mariage
le constituant et le législateur ont
bien inscrit cette institution dans le
processus de conquête des libertés
individuelles avec le
temps avec le temps il est ensuite ancré
dans le principe
d'égalité lorsque en
1938 il abroche l'obéissance du par les
vous à son mari inscrit dans l'article
213 et lorsqu'en 1970 et en
1975 il cesse de faire référence aux
chefs de famille pour reconnaître la
communauté de vie et l'égalité des
droits et des devoirs il avance vers
l'égalité également d'ailleurs avec la
loi qui
rétablit ce qui existait déjà en 1792 le
divorce par consentement mutuel
il y a aussi un acte de fraternité
lorsque par la loi de janvier
1972 le législateur décide de supprimer
toute distinction entre les enfants
légitimes et les enfants dinaturels et
que de 2000 à 2005 il abroge sous
pression européenne d'ailleurs les
discriminations qui continuent à frapper
les enfant adultérrain et qu'après il
supprime il élimine du Code civil la
notion même d'enfants légitimes et
d'enfants adultérrains le mariage est
donc oui un acte de liberté la liberté
de se choisir la liberté de vivre
ensemble la liberté de divorcer la
liberté aussi de ne pas se marier
puisque aujourd'hui un enfant sur deux
nî hors mariage en l'ouvrant au couple
de même sexe nous en faisons un acte
d'égalité l'égalité des droits pour tous
les couples l'égalité des droits pour
toutes les
familles et il y a bien aussi un acte de
fraternité en ouvrant cette institution
éminemment républicaine à tous les
couples aux couples hétérosexuels et au
coupes
homosexuel et cela sans aucun préjudice
sur l'institution du mariage parce que
ce mariage est ouvert à droit constant
ces dispositions sociales demeurent par
conséquent c'est-à-dire l'assistance le
secours le
respect ses obligations et ses effets
d'ordre public aussi les conditions
d'âge et de consentement les obligations
les prohibitions sur l'inceste et sur la
polygamie ainsi que les protections
juridiques et les sécurités autrement
dit cette institution du mariage qui a
été une institution de propriété aut
temps où on alli surtous les patrimoines
qui a été une institution de
domination du temps où la loi ordonnait
obéissance à l'épouse qui a été une
institution de possession du mari sur
les sur la femme et sur les enfants qui
a été une institution d'exclusion
d'exclusion sur la base de la religion
d'exclusion sur la base de la profession
d'exclusion sur la base des non
croyances cette institution est en train
de devenir univers
parce qu'elle cesse de témoigner d'un
ordre social où la puissance publique
établirait une hiérarchie dans la
sexualité alors que nous avons supprimé
de notre droit toute pénalisation de
l'homosexualité et toute discrimination
à l'encontre des personnes
homosexuelles alors que contient
ceexte d'abord je vi de mariage et
l'adoption à droit constant au couple
homosexuel c'est-à-dire dans les mêmes
conditions avec les mêmes obligations
les mêmes protection et les mêmes
sécurités c'est donc bien un accueil
dans la maison commune
ensuite oui les mêmes droits les mêmes
devoir ensuite il rappelle le rôle du
procureur de la République auprès des
officiers d'état civil il réaffirme que
le mariage est une cérémonie
républicaine et publique
il élargit les possibilités de lieu de
célébration possibilités qui profitent
également aux couples
hétérosexuels il permet à des couples de
Français ou d'un français et d'un
étranger d'une Française et d'une
étrangère qui réside dans un pays qui ne
reconnaît pas le mariage des couples de
même sexe de pouvoir se marié en France
dans des conditions de lieux qui sont
encadré par la
loi ce texte définit également des
conditions
d'adoption d'abord il est bon de
rappeler que l'adoption s'effectuera
dans les mêmes conditions pour les
couples homosexuels que pour les couples
hétérosexuels c'est-à-dire à droit
constant c'est-à-dire à droit
constant avec un agrément du conseil
général à la suite d'une enquête
rigoureuse que certains d'ailleurs
jugent intrusive et surtout à la suite
de la décision d'un juge qui estimant
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
conformément à l'article 353 du Code
civil va décider ou non d'attribuer
l'adoption au couple demandeur
ensuite ce texte apporte de la sécurité
pour les enfants ces enfants qui sont
élevés par de parents mais dans les
liens affectifs et matériels ne sont
reconnus que pour un seul
et qui en cas de décès de ce parent se
retrouve orphelin et ne peuvent pas
continuer à vivre avec le deuxème parent
le texte va protéger ses enfants en leur
apportant une sécurité
juridique ce texte permet également
l'adoption pligniaire de l'enfant du
conjoint ou de la conjointe y compris
lorsque cet enfant a été adopté de façon
pliniiaire il permet l'adoption simple
dans les mêmes condition la commission
des Lois du Sénat a souhaité restreindre
cette possibilité aux enfants qui ne
dispose que d'une filiation biologique
afin de limiter la pluri
parentalité ce texte permet également un
exercice plus facile de l'autorité
parentale et c'est une disposition qui
profitera également au couples
hétérosexuel et aux familles
hétéroparentales enfin ce texte permet
que dans le d'une séparation qui serait
intervenue avant la promulgation de la
loi qui vous est soumise du projet de
loi qui vous est soumis que le juge
puisse prononcer le maintien éventuel
des liens de l'enfant avec le parent
séparé qui n'en a pas la garde sur la
base évidemment de l'intérêt supérieur
de l'enfant et la commission des Lois du
Sénat a souhaitter renforcer cette
disposition en rendant obligatoire à
peine de
nullité formation du tribunal sur
l'existence d'un ancien parent
social ce texte organise également la
dévolution du nom patronymique dans le
projet de loi présenté à l'Assemblée
nationale le gouvernement avait
introduit pour les seul couple
homosexuel une disposition qui
permettait en cas de désaccord des
parents d'attribuer le N un nom aux
enfants en retenant un seul nom par
parent nom qui serait accollé par ordre
alphabétique la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale a souhaité
généraliser le dispositif et l' donc
étendu aux couples et aux familles
hétéroparentales lors du débat à
l'Assemblée nationale au nom du
gouvernement j'ai estimé que une partie
des arguments qui étaient présentés par
l'opposition avaient toute leur
pertinence et j'ai souhaité que à
l'occasion de la navette parlementaire
la réflexion puisse murir et que le
Sénat puisse voir quelle disposition
serait la meilleure concernant
l'attribution du nom patronymi la
commission des Lois du Sénat a estimé
qu'il valait mieux maintenir cette
organisation prévu par le gouvernement
pour les couples homosexuels et les
familles homoparentales que pour les
couples hétérosexueles et les familles
hétéroparentales il a distingué d'un
côté le
c'est-à-dire la situation où les parents
ne se prononcent pas sur l'attribution
du nom et dans ce cas c'est le nom du
père qui a attribué et d'un autre côté
le désaccord entre les parents dans ce
cas ce sont les deux noms dans la limite
d'un nom par parent
avec l'ordre le respect de l'ordre
alphabétique j'attire néanmoins
l'attention sur une interpellation des
Nations Unies à l'égard de la France à
propos de cette
prééance systématique du nom du père aux
enfants dans ces
cas-là ensuite ce texte organise bien
entendu la coordination des dispositions
telles qu'elles peuvent être induites
par l'ouverture du mariage et de
l'adoption au couple de même sexe le
gouvernement avait choisi un mode
d'écriture qui correspond à la règle
légistique générale et qui aboutissait
en dehors du titre 7 qui organise
l'affiliation aboutissait à la
coordination des articles concernés dans
le Code civil et dans les autres codes
lois et ordonnan la commission des Lois
du Sénat suivie par l'Assemblée a choisi
une autre forme d'écriture en
privilégiant une disposition
interprétative que l'on appelle
trivialement un article balai cette
disposition interprétative est
introduite avant le titre premier du
Code civil et elle procède donc à une
interprétation de toutes les
dispositions du Code civil et d'autres
articles procédent à la coordination
pour les autres codes la commission des
Lois du Sénat a choisi une troisè
solution elle a choisi d'élaborer un
principe général selon lequel le mariage
et l'adoption produisent des effets de
droit identiques que les parents soient
de coup de sexe différents ou de même
sexe évidemment cette disposition sera
adossée à une habilitation qui est
prévue dans le texte pour que le
gouvernement puisse prendre les
dispositions par ordonnance et procéder
aux coordinations nécessaires dans les 6
mois évidemment tout cela en respect des
dispositions de l'article 38 de la
Constitution sur l'habilitation et et et
le pouvoir de légiféré par
ordonnance quelques dispositions
diverses ont également été introduites
elle concerne la reconnaissance d'un
mariage légalement établi dans un pays
qui reconnaît le mariage des couples de
même sexe avec des effets immédiats pour
le couple et la retranscription la
transcription au registre d'état civil
français de ce mariage avec effet à
partir de la transcription vis-à-vis des
enfants et vis-à-vis des tiers cette ces
dispositions évidemment sont établis
sous réserve du respect des articles du
Code civil qui régissent le mariage qui
régissent l'adoption et évidemment les
articles qui régissent le la
transcription au registre d'état
civil enfin le périmètre du texte ou
plus précisément ce qui ne n'est pas
contenu dans le texte le Sénat la
commission des lois et la commission des
affaires sociales qui se sont réunis
ensemble on décidé de maintenir le
périmètre du texte en l'état où il avait
été présenté dans le projet de loi
gouvernementale et de son enrichissement
par l'Assemblée nationale à savoir le
mariage et l'adoption et quelques
dispositions connexes que j'ai indiqué
tout à l'heure ce texte ne contient pas
de dispositions relativ à l'assistance
médicale à la procréation tout en
considérant que le sujet est légitime le
chef du gouvernement a estimé qui devait
faire l'objet d'un autre texte de loi ce
texte de loi sera présenté par la
ministre de la Famille Dominique
bertinoti qui vous en parlera plus
savemment tout à l'heure et le Conseil
national consultatif d'éthique c'est
autosaisie du sujet il a annoncé son
rapport pour le 3e trimestre de cette
année le premier ministre a choisi
d'attendre cet apport C ce rapport pour
en connaître la vie et
le texte de conduit par porté par la
ministre de la Famille en tirera toutes
les conséquences il faut rappeler que
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
est aujourd'hui en l'état de notre droit
dans le Code de la Santé publicque alors
que le mariage et l'adoption concerne
relève du Code civil parce que le
mariage et l'adoption concerne les
libertés et l'état des personnes
l'assistance à la procréation concerne
les couples mariés ou non stabl les
couples hétérosexuels et elle est
accordée sur présentation sur
justification médicale les pays qui ont
ouvert le mariage et l'adoption et qui
ont aussi ouvert l'assistance médicale à
la procréation au couple de femmes et
très souvent aux femmes célibataires
l'en fait dans des textes différents
pour la plupart dans des textes de
bioéthique à l'exception des Pays-Bas
qui l'ont inscrit dans un texte sur
l'égalité de
traitement la GPA ne fait pas partie non
plus du périmètre du texte le le le
président de la République ainsi que le
premier ministre ont réaffirmé ont
réaffirmé leur
attachement leur attachement au principe
d'ordre public
d'indisponibilité du corps humain un
attachement que j'ai moi-même également
réaffirmé et et si la GPA ne fait pas
l'objet de débat mais mérite néanmoins
effectivement d'être signalé cela peut
être en référence à une proposition de
loi déposée au Sénat concernant la
pratique de la GPA et don des signataire
viennent d'ailleurs de
San je veux remercier le travail qui a
été effectué par la commission des lois
et la commission des affaires sociales
qui se sont réunis concomitamment qui
ont enrichi le le texte de façon
significative remercier le président de
la commission des lois jean-Pierre Sueur
et le rapporteur de la commission des
lois Jean-Pierre Michel la présidente de
la commission des lois Annie David ainsi
que la rapporteur Michel meunier pour le
travail de très grande qualité qui a été
fourni je veux rester un instant sur les
sécurités les protections que ce texte
de loi promet dorén avant le les
dispositions de protection pour les
conjoints sont
évidentes le régime social le régime
fiscal ainsi que les droits liés à la
rupture ou au décès seront assurés
désormais pour les couples qui ont
décidé de s'inscrire dans la durée dans
un projet conjugal et ou un projet
parental autrement dit ce qui est dû
sera rendu et l'État y veillera par son
administration ou par le juge nous ne
disposons d'aucun élément ni
scientifique ni statistique ni même
empirique pour penser que les couples
homosexuels se montreraient plus
raisonnbl que les couples hétérosexuels
en cas de rupture il est assez peu
probable il est assez peu probable qu'il
résiste plus que les couples
hétérosexuel à cette étrange fureur qui
s'empare de ceux qui se sont
passionnément aimés et qui au moment de
la
rupture deviennent d'inflexibles
adversaires quand ce ne sont pas
d'intértables ennemis alors il n'en sera
pas toujours ainsi mais quand cela sera
il faut que le juge puisse s'en mêler
que le juge puisse protéger la plus
vulnérable ou le plus vulnérable des
conjointes ou des conjoints qui puisse
veiller à l'intérêt des enfants
sauvegarder ses intérêts
maintenir ou non ou encadrer les
relations avec le parent qui n'en a pas
la garde assurer le maintien des droits
préserver le respect des devoirs et
peut-être sans le dire donner ce conseil
de Paul
Berlin surtout soyons-nous l'un à
l'autre
indulgent parce que c'est bien au juges
qu'il appartiendra de rappeler c'est au
juges qu'il appartiendra de rappeler que
les enfants par le mariage entrent dans
la famille de chacun des conjoints que
le mariage n'est pas qu'une relation
entre deux personnes et que la
transmission de génération se fait dans
le cadre élargi des deux familles quant
au regard social qui pèse lourdement
parfois
désapprobateur sur les enfants de ses
familles ce regard social qui insinue
une anormalité marge une bizarrerie il
peut bouleverser il peut perturber il
peut troubler considérablement et ce
même regard social parfois pire que cela
des mots des actes des
agressions peuvent avoir des effets
potentiellement aussi dévastateurs sur
les
adolescents désormais avec ce texte de
loi ceux qui pent ses regards sur ses
enfants sur ses adolescents sur ses
familles savent que ces familles ces
enfants ces adolescents ne sont plus
seulement tolérés admis dans la société
mais qu' sont protégé par la
loi et cela nous permet de passer
justement de la tolérance à l'égalité et
je vous garantis que cela fera la
différence quelques mots sur les autres
mèes quelques mots sur les outres m je
veux saluer les sénateurs des Outremers
qui sembleil ils seront plus nombreux
que les députés des outremèes à votter
ce texte de loi je veux saluer
leur je n'étais pas habitué à des
oUI NON NON à des propos de grossièreté
dans cette maison je suis un peu
surprise je suis un peu
surprise peu importe de qui peu importe
de qui je suis surprise je disais donc
que c'est c'est sénateurs je veux saluer
leur courage parce que je sais qu'ils
choisissent leurs conviction ils
choisissent leur conscience ils
choisissent leur valeurs comme d'autres
parlementaires de l'Hexagone comme
d'autres parlementaires qui même dans un
contexte social et culturel difficile
choisissent ce qui est juste et nous
avons suffisamment de référenceces dans
notre histoire commune de ces combats
pour l'égalité c'est bien dans cette
filiation et dans cet héritage que nous
nous
situons il nous faut admettre il nous
faut
admettre que à travers le temps
l'institution du mariage témoigne de la
démocratisation des liens privés des
rapports
sociaux et que cette institution a suivi
l'évolution sociale et culturelle de la
société parfois elle a un peu forcé mais
chaque fois qu'elle l'a fait en dire ch
de la liberté et de l'égalité nous
n'avons pas eu à nous en plaindre en
dehors des de ceux qui sont accrochés à
un ordre immuable et
inégalitaire ainsi en passant du
sacrement matrimonial qui d'ailleurs n'a
pas toujours existé il n'a été instauré
qu'en
1215 en passant du sacrement matrimonial
au mariage
civille l'institution a admis le
pluralisme religieux d'abord et ensuite
et ensuite le pluralisme civique en
ouvrant le mariage et l'adoption au
couple de même sexe nous franchissons un
pas vers la reconnaissance du pluralisme
familial et cela sans dégât parce que
qu'il y a-t-il de plus précieux pour les
familles hétéroparentales pour les
couples homosexuels dans l'institution
du
mariage d'abord l'affiliation biologique
elle est régie par le titre
du Code civil qui ne bouge pas d'une
virgule
ensuite la présomption de
paternité elle demeure absolument
intacte et puis l'encadrement de la
séparation et la préservation des droits
mais il n'y a aucune soustraction les
droits sont étendus ils ne sont pas
réduits par contre ceux qui étai
inachevé à savoir l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale à savoir la
souplesse pour la détermination du
lieu de la célébration du mariage à
l'initiative exclusive des épous ou des
époux nous y avons veillé à l'Assemblée
nationale sont introduits pour tous à la
faveur de ce texte et donc profiteront
aux familles
htéroparentales par ailleurs ce projet
de loi sur la famille auquel travaille
déjà la ministre de la Famille
introduira des améliorations
substantielle sur le statut des familles
recomposées et sur les régimes
d'adoption et les familles
hétéroparental par la simple loi du
nombre en profiteront beaucoup plus que
les familles
homoparental nous sommes donc bien face
à l'altérité mais avec grand
plaisir et si vous m'aviez fait si vous
m'aviez fait un accueil plus cordial je
vous aurais regardé plus souvent avec
bonheur nous sommes donc dans
l'altérité non pas l'altérité
strictement sexuelle parce que aucun
d'entre nous ne se réduit ni à son
appartenance de gens ni à son
orientation sexuelle nous sommes
infiniment plus que cela je parle plutôt
d'une altérité que je dirais majuscule
j'aurais dit une altérité absolue mais
il aurait là un oxyor parce que
l'altérité qui fait à l'autre nous
renvoie justement à nous et à ce qui est
relatif en nous c'est ce que c'est ce
que définit gel qui est c cité par zan
Todorov lorsqu'il affirme que il faut
pour le moins être deux pour être humain
et humain est au singulier parce que
c'est bien le souci de l'autre qui me
permet d'affirmer mon humanité et
socialement ma civilité
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
vous remercie pour l'accueil que vous
allez réserver à ce débat je sais que je
suis dans une maison dans la culture
pousse davantage vers le fond et vers le
droit que vers les joutes et les
polémiques vous savez que ce que nous
faisons là ce ne sont pas que des mots
et par cette action dirais C nous
forçons de fumantes portes je vous
remercie